NATO defense ministers meanwhile are
meeting for a second day in Brussels as
well as more military aid for Ukraine
the focus is on Vladimir Putin's big
threats to use nuclear weapons here's a
look at Russia's nuclear Arsenal
the war in Ukraine has once again raised
a specter many had hoped Humanity cast
out years ago
nuclear war
sha currently has more nuclear weapons
than any other nuclear power
the exact number is a closely guarded
secret but intelligent Services pegged
the number at around 6 000 Warheads
the vast majority are so-called
strategic nuclear weapons
normally deployed on intercontinental
ballistic missiles strategic nuclear
weapons have the capability to destroy
entire cities in one strike
they're part of a nuclear deterrent
strategy
military planners argue governments
would be reluctant to attack a country
if they knew they possessed these
doomsday weapons
given the raw destructive power and
Ukraine shared border with Russia
experts argue Moscow is unlikely to
deploy a strategic nuclear weapon
however there is another option
so-called tactical nuclear weapons they
can be fired from traditional weapon
systems like cruise missiles while they
are between 10 and 100 times less
powerful than their strategic cousins
they still pack enough power to wipe out
hardened targets without producing
widespread radioactive fallout
Russia's iskander missile system has
already found use throughout the current
conflict and can easily fire tactical
nuclear weapons of which Russia is
thought to possess some 2000.
I spoke earlier with Roland freudenstein
the vice president of the security Think
Tank Globe sack we talked about about
NATO's meeting on NATO holding a
planning group meeting their nuclear
plan group meeting I asked him how
concerned NATO is about the possibility
of Russia using nuclear weapons in
Ukraine
and this is really the The crucial Point
here
um it's not the question whether Putin
is serious or not the question is how do
we react to his vague nuclear threats
and I think the idea that we need to
deter him is a very good one
now Germany's defense minister Christina
lambrecht says that NATO should adapt
accordingly to Russia's nuclear threats
any idea what she means by that
I do not know exactly I know there are
other politicians from her party like
golf mitsanis the chief whip in the
bundestag of the SPD who has already
indicated that we should be more ready
to negotiate with Russia now I think as
a reaction to nuclear threats that's
really the wrong course I mean that is
signaling to Putin that he is getting
somewhere with his threats
um if she the minister had in mind that
we should we should adapt our tactics
and talk to each other to coordinate how
to react to nuclear threats and the
possible use of nuclear weapons
um she has my full support and I think
then she is right
Russia is due to hold its nuclear
exercises soon uh possibly at the same
time that NATO is doing exactly that is
there a risk in this situation Roland
that the other side's intentions will be
misread is there a risk of
miscalculation here
that risk is extremely low because
during the Cold War uh the the U.S and
the Soviet Union have established
channels of communication which still
exists between the militaries and also
between the political leaderships uh so
there is there is the so-called hotline
um between Washington and Moscow and I
do not see
um a significant risk of of
unintentional escalation here
now Germany and 14 other countries uh
have agreed on plans for a better
European air defense system what can you
tell us about that Roman
well the the sad fact is that basically
for the last 20 years since 2002
um NATO armed forces have concentrated
on a different kind of threat more from
uh transnational terrorist organizations
and those organizations do not possess
jet planes so air defense was neglected
painfully neglected during most of that
time after 2014 with Crimea and donbass
and the increasing Russian threats of um
a return to militarized imperialism uh I
think there has been to a certain degree
a turnaround in NATO policy but that
still has to take shape so at the moment
NATO NATO air defenses are
underdeveloped and we have to shape up
pretty quickly okay so they're making up
for that deficit NATO countries Roland
have been giving a lot of their military
hardware to you crane could this be
making the alliance itself more
vulnerable
no
every tank given to Ukraine
improves our security also a leopard two
tank from Germany is worth many times
more on the battlefield in Ukraine than
in some kind of military Depot
in a German Garrison so you know
actually providing weapons to Ukraine
increases our security because it means
that the Russian military threat to us
will also diminish
Roland thank you very much for talking
with us that was Roland freudenstein
vice president of the think tank Globe
sack
well NATO has issued a sharp warning to
Russia not to use nuclear weapons in
Ukraine Secretary General Yen
stoltenberg said any use of nuclear arms
would fundamentally change the nature of
the war
Russia's nuclear retric is dangerous
Reckless and they know that if they use
nuclear weapon against
uh Ukraine it will have severe
consequences and I also know that a
nuclear war cannot be won engineer
before
and standing by in Brussels Forest is
our correspondent Terry Schultz uh Terry
you were following that entire news
conference it went on for more than 20
minutes uh what are your main takeaways
from what the Secretary General said
certainly today a lot of the focus was
on this question of nuclear rhetoric
coming out of the Kremlin everyone is
worried about the unpredictably of
Russian unpredictability of Russian
President Vladimir Putin and so while
NATO says that it has not seen any any
practical change in the posture of
Russia's nuclear Arsenal nobody can take
that for granted and so this is why
they're going ahead with this this long
planned exercise next week and and why
the the deterrence messages continue to
be issued from NATO headquarters here
nobody wants President Putin to think
he's going to be able to get away with
this now they say that they would not
respond in a nuclear way but certainly
Russia would be made to feel the
consequences in a most severe manner if
he were to use any any kind of nuclear
weapon against Ukraine
the NATO defense minister is of course
covering a lot of ground there over the
past couple of days we are hearing also
that they uh the several NATO members
want to create a joint
anti-uh anti-missile shield for Europe
tell us more about that
yes this is a german-led initiative
pressure and since so much equipment is
being sent to Ukraine and today on the
sidelines of the defense Minister's
meetings 14 allies and Finland which is
most likely soon to be an ally signed an
agreement that they would start working
together on on missile defense on air
defense more broadly and that means that
they wouldn't each just be buying
National systems they would jointly
procure them they would make sure that
all of these these this equipment works
together and this is a big deal this is
something NATO has wanted to see for
many many years and now it seems that
the pressure from the war on Ukraine the
pressure on on resources is finally
making countries work together this is
going to be a big Improvement in in air
defense but also simply in cost of
efficiency for purchases
now NATO carries out uh nuclear
exercises Readiness exercises every year
and they're going to con they're going
to go ahead with theirs this year
despite the war in Ukraine Terry is
there a risk that Russia could see that
as a provocation
Russia tends to describe everything NATO
does as a provocation so I don't think
that's going to deter anyone in NATO
from carrying out these exercises in
fact everyone that I've spoken with says
that if we were to even think about
canceling this exercise that would send
the message that bullying works that
this nuclear saber rattling works and it
would in fact even empower the Kremlin
to think about using nuclear weapons
because they would see that that Western
allies are are backing down so I'm told
that there was never any consideration
about calling off the exercise this year
Terry thank you very much our
correspondent Terry Schultz there in
Brussels